tonight is a very special night there's
a little event coming up called the
all-star game now there is something
that has been missing the all-star draft
we are bringing it back from the dead
and today we have a very special guest
it is biz
nasty biz where you at what are you up
to here buddy don't worry about where i
am buddy you seem a little bit nervous
off that inch are you okay
what's your heart right now you've got
100 no stumbling over the words i'm
dressed nice you're just showing up with
the cowboy hat on all right i'm going
bill belichick style here okay i'm also
i'm gonna be all serious but very laid
back like he was at his at the giraffe
with the with the dog in the house at
the at the dinner table
okay i like that so let me run you
through the rules real quick we are
going to do a 10 player draft with all
the choices of the players available you
can sort that however you want if you
don't want to have any defenders on your
team you don't need them sound good that
sounds great i like those rolls now how
are we going to decide who goes first
uh i have a deck of cards
do you have a deck of cards as well
i have a deck of cards
you do have decorations i have a
stopwatch because there's a time limit
on this i'm going to put your mind in a
pretzel all night long on the draft
board here so let's what are we doing
drawing highest card for who gets the
the first pick yeah let's see legit i
want to see an actual bridge shuffle
going down okay yes i like this i will
do the same here i'll even close my
laptop and close my eyes for you okay
because you play this card wins here all
right three
two
one
good start for busy boy
i i think we're ready to go
you want to get us started here i'll uh
i'll put 30 seconds on the clock i don't
know if you're gonna take that long here
for pick one but we'll see what you have
in store we already have a jersey made
for this guy we got uh andre vasilevskiy
okay the foundation to any great team is
in goal and you look at the last two
playoff runs they had back-to-back
championships he didn't lose
back-to-back games one time on the way
to two stanley cup so he's a bread
winner and he's gonna be the foundation
to our team welcome to the squad
vasilevskiy i'm just gonna stick with
his last name here and keep it really
simple i think everybody gets the point
maybe shorten it put just vassi on there
just so you get the the spelling correct
and another thing too a little fun fact
for you people at home i was not maybe
the biggest cat person and then i got to
sit down with vasilevskiy at the nhl
media scrums in chicago one year before
the season started and he actually got
me to uh to start liking cats so the guy
has a tons of power and tons of
influence and he's gonna have a ton of
influence in that locker room on winning
some games
i like that biz i like that all right
my first pick you know this is a tough
one right uh i i think my goal for this
draft is just to not get tripped too
hard on the internet so you took vasty
number one which is maybe a bit
questionable i think you you will maybe
get some hate for that i'm gonna go
ahead and take the man
the guy that's gonna go through four
guys on the ice when there's only three
out there
conor mcdavid at uh at my first overall
pick
with all the drama they got going on
right now i don't want those types of
headaches in my locker room to be quite
frank i don't want their their media
following my team yep and getting
given harassing questions in the media
scrums if by chance they lose a three on
three match so i mean i'd say
easily a rookie mistake in your first
all-star selection there nasher but go
ahead and take it away pick number two
well i'm gonna have to go uh with my
former well i guess current still
current he did chirp me about being
cheap because i walked out of the bill
one time but that's nor hearing over
there
local arizona kid he's going to his
fourth all-star game he's got 10 goals
in his last eight road games so he can't
just get it done at home he gets it done
on the road uh his sixth season as the
maple leaf 25 tucks each of those
seasons austin matthews and a little
dedication to austin with the stash
pablo
welcome to the lineup
i like that pick this i like that pick i
thought about taking him number one it
was definitely a toss-up that's a good
one no you can't go wrong with that and
he's also getting a c on my squad
okay i'm taking it right off of my uh my
chest here and i'm giving it to him all
right you left the combo alive dry
saddle he's going to be playing with
some angry you're going to be playing
with some fire after the interview that
went down today uh we're going to be
taking dry sidle putting him and mcdavid
on line number one here is it my turn
now you got your your guy written down
huber doll i do have them written down
we went from the most uh barkov being
the most underrated player in the league
to huberto he's leading the league in
assists by three i think he's got 38 on
the year and who's going to feed the
puck to one of the nastiest goal scorers
on the planet matthews
the best pastor so huge rookie mistake
by you hubie and we're on a nickname
basis by the way hubie yeah i i figured
you would be i figured it would be
that's a tough one to spell as well and
he's got the assistant captaincy as well
his uh his agent alan walsh will
probably be giving it to you on twitter
if you're not picking them too and
giving them the snub there lisa we're
not going to be intimidated by any
agents here biz we're all business all
right
so you got hubby in there uh now now the
thing is do i do i want to focus on the
d this early on there i think there's a
clear number one defenseman in this
draft and i you know what he may as well
be a forward we're taking the elite edge
machine
the guy that only scores nasty goals
kale mccarr
toss him in that first line v
i mean i can't i can't deny that pick
he's uh
to me he's probably the most impressive
defenseman since paul coffey came around
now i wasn't really around for much of
pal coffee's career because i was so
young and and wasn't really able to
absorb it and give it the credit that it
deserves but rick tockett told me a lot
of similarities in the way he moves up
and down the ice so i can't fault you
for for that one
speaking of snubs this next guy
i the fact that he wasn't uh or it had
to go to the last man standing and for
him to get voted in uh he's gonna be
coming into this all-star game extremely
motivated uh let's hope he keeps it on
the rails on like playoffs uh this is
actually going to be his first
all-star game shockingly he's fifth in
league scoring right now that's why i'm
shocked that he was snubbed to begin
with and
and not to boot it's a contract here we
all know how that's the moolah motivates
guys welcome to the squad nazim kadri
i love it dude
there was nothing more hype than when he
buried that shootout winner with the
announcer yelling about him penned to
vegas and then him actually getting
voted in you just you can't write a
better story than that one i'll give him
an a2
no it was great and uh he plays with an
edge too so keep your tell your guys to
keep their heads up out there all right
biz i uh i'm at a loss of words as to
how this player is still available in
the draft probably the funniest guy in
the league uh last time when there was
an nhl all-star draft this guy was
begging to be picked last he's not
getting picked last today we are taking
alexander ovechkin sitting him in that
left circle and uh guaranteeing at least
a hat-trick a game out of him he's an
electric factory i don't blame that pick
going back to a few all-star games ago
and a little fun fact for you people at
home i believe he's going to be leading
the way with his eighth nod for
everybody involved in this all-star game
20 guys it's their first time but i
forget which one it was it might have
been the all-star game in montreal at
the bell center where he put the cowboy
hat on and he electrified the crowd so
this guy i i don't blame you for that
pick so i wish i could smack talky but i
can't this pick for me might come a
little bit off the board but uh in this
type of format you need also forwards
being responsible because there aren't
many defensemen and i can't think of a
better 200-foot forward in the national
hockey league than mark stone okay
always up for the selkie he can
contribute on offense he's gonna be
great in the locker room he's used to
that chaotic environment if i said that
properly chaotic and
it's at home for him is this his first
all-star as well
mine no i usually no no stoner oh yeah
you oh well i i just thought you were
bringing up the fact that i was a
two-time echl all-star in the minor so i
just
must have crossed my mind there we will
move on
again i mean we're talking electric guys
i think with this all-star game i mean
you got stoner there it's nice to get
the guys that are in there first right
there's a little bit of hype a little
bit of buzz uh we're going to take
carrill the thrill caprice off this
guy's been flying out there young guy
first time in an all-star game uh no
shot he goes out there and does not put
on a show for us
i mean i just i like the pick because
ovi's gonna make him comfortable in the
locker room right you have that russian
connection and as far as kapricov's
concern he's uh he's used to the big
stage as well he scored the the sh what
was it the overtime winner in the gold
medal game against germany in the last
olympics so they're probably going to be
trying to take it out on my squad given
the fact that they can't go represent
their countries this year so i mean
all-star game olympics i mean
competitive nature it's neck and neck
yup i love it man you're hey you're
hyping up you're uh hyping up my picks
for me which i do greatly appreciate
here yeah somebody must have handed you
a sniffer and you woke up um listen the
all-star game it's not all about these
fancy goals from the perimeter and
dangling it's about getting to the blue
paint and scoring the goals that matter
late in games crunch time when guys are
actually buckling down and i want joe
pavelski on my team everybody thought he
hit a certain age and he was going to
fade off into the sunset and not compete
anymore he's already got 20 tucks this
year and
it's his fourth all-star game
experience you always need experience in
the locker room
and he's really good at everything
including golf he's a big hunter
pabs is
biz i want to be honest with you right
now your last few picks you know i'm
looking at my list
and and these guys are maybe not even
cracking the top 20. oh that's cute how
many how many conference finals has dry
side eliminated into just just the top
of my head how many
you're right but listen pavelski's the
type of guy he's he's scoring the
and are we really getting greasy tips in
front in all-star games no we're looking
for missions we're looking for ziggers
baseball bats we're looking for we're
looking for some crazy stuff out here
biz maybe your maybe your team won't be
but my team will one guy will you need a
little bit of everything i mentioned
that 200-foot game from stone coming in
defensive poet checks on the way back
you think goldie's going to be back
checking like stone is he'll probably be
hung over from bottle service from the
night before stone's going to be
you're right you're ready
i can't disagree in bed with the wife
and kids and we're good to go yep i'm
just going right down right down the
list here you're literally letting me
walk walk right down this thing uh
listen we got one of the best defenders
in the league the next paul coffee as as
you as you claimed with kayla mccarr we
are going to take uh
you know that maybe the next best right
behind him adam fox new york rangers
speedy young guy these are guys him and
kale both may as well be forwards
they're going out there can play some
defense as well it's the best of both
worlds for me biz you got to remember
there's only one puck out there right so
you have all these guys who who really
really like it so i don't know if you
just knew that this one was going to be
played with one well it looks like
you're actually going deep into your
notes i see you flipping pages
yeah i'm a little torn here on this next
one and you know what i'm gonna lean
back to loyalty because that's what my
team's about to and this is a guy he'll
be in his second all-star game and a guy
who i've seen make strides year over
year with the arizona coyotes
organization
clayton keller
great kid needed to put a little weight
on in the off season came back 10 pounds
stronger he's got that half a step that
he needs and that's why he's been
lighting up that pacific division okay
another another probably surprise
surprise pick from some of you but as i
said loyalty matters on my team another
another off the board pick i got to say
uh biz that one that one is not even on
my list uh you know not even a a
consideration here
what's that i said you didn't think i'd
be picking a coyote with my reverse
record no i knew you did i think you
just wanted to you just wanted to do the
little how thing i mean let's be honest
here this one you know i'm gonna do my
my first debatably off the board pick
here uh this is a guy
that buried five goals a guy that jumped
from 30th to 10th place
in league scoring overnight that i it
just hasn't been done we're talking
timo meyer
a little bit off the board maybe
somebody that uh you know the people
didn't expect but i listen he's hot
right now he's a guy that i gotta take
and that san jose team has been
surprising a lot of teams in that
pacific division
and uh and i can't deny that one you
know what this one another one is going
to be more of a loyalty pick and it's
kind of a
more of an emotional story for the
people at home jack campbell he was
selected for his first all-star game i
actually played with him in the american
hockey league okay he was drafted in the
first round by the dallas stars and i
think given the amount of pressure being
a first rounder he really lost his game
well after getting traded over the la
kings organization i had him on ontario
uh in the minors with the reign and he
was able to to find his game again and
he's battled all the way back he went up
to la and then ended up getting trade
over i believe with kyle clifford
in a move that brought him to the
toronto maple leafs and now he's their
starting goaltender he's having a vesna
caliber season i'd say he's probably
third in line right now and i couldn't
be happier for you jacko welcome to the
squad jack campbell soupy
soupy
love that pick
see we're gonna have so much chemistry
in that locker room they won't even know
what to do with it
up next for me
listen we we need a guy that's gonna get
the fans going a little bit you know
we're in vegas
you know there's a little bit of
electricity in the air
maybe i mean maybe some sticks need to
be thrown into the stands some may say
i'm grabbing a guy that can get some ot
goals for us if it comes to that and
that is my man jack hughes
he's like he's like the tick tock
generation hockey player all these new
kids love him him zigras i mean you
could throw throw troy terry in the mix
there
do you know any tock dances
i
is that how you do it
what do you what do you call that one i
always talk about
dances they're always like that's that's
like a little little renegade yeah i
like that let's go [ __ ] do you have a
ticket somebody behind you laughing can
we please have this person removed from
the room i don't need those types of
distractions in here and negativity i
don't want any negativity in my locker
room
yeah
biz the people would love you on the on
the talk for sure
i'm not gonna roll in here no i have too
many things going on like
dumbing you in this draft
uh you somehow had time to put some yarn
on a board but
so i haven't drafted a defenseman yet
and you're gonna think oh this one's off
the board too who's gonna play actual
defense other than the guys that i said
are gonna have to share a puck on your
back end
pelic from the new york islanders
as defensive as they come always a
guaranteed clean breakout pass he's not
going to be pinching what he doesn't
need to because he's got the rest of the
guys to provide the offense and he
always gets pucks through when he gets
them at the point and who's going to be
there in front of the night tipping it
in joe pavelski already planned it out
with my brain keep the change baby
that's i mean that's an interesting pick
i know
listen you're maybe more of a a bit more
old-school than me you like these
stay-at-home defenders i went with the
guys that uh they'll just be rushing the
rushing off the ice coast to coast so
i'm kidding
by the end of this game
you'll be pissing blood
okay well if you're gonna go without if
you're gonna go that route uh well
actually you know what it's probably
time for me to to pick a goaltender i
probably should get that off the board
so you've taken vassi and campbell away
from me both both very solid picks uh
i'm gonna go with the red hot carolina
hurricanes we're gonna get our boy
freddy anderson
into the mix
that sucks because i would have liked
him too for the connection with austin
matthews but a great goalie so you were
gonna go with the uh
probably never done before three goalie
pick for your team if it came to it
with some of the guys you
goalies
have
be contributing more at least on the
back end um
all right pixen
um we actually just interviewed him for
our podcast and uh a kid that uh not
only did joe sakic when he was growing
up say i think this guy's got a bright
future in the national hockey league saw
it at that young of an age and then paul
korea also with the same organization
said i think this kid's got something
special and he's having a breakout
season with the anaheim ducks troy terry
another guy
who was last man in
i just think that they're going to be
coming in with a chip on their shoulder
and i don't need that many guys playing
that hardcore defense because i talked
about the 200-foot game there
so troy terry one of the more undercover
pass good passers in the league too
troy terry yeah man him on that streak
was just something special to watch he's
made anaheim uh you know something
something to turn into him milano and
zegras all going at it when we talk i do
actually really like that and we talk
about rising to the occasion if you go
back to 2017 he was a guy who had three
uh shootouts
in uh in that semi-final game against
russia at the world juniors he ends up
advancing them to the finals against
canada and then he had a big game in the
finals ends up winning a gold medal
three months later after coming back
from injury at denver wins a national
championship so we talk about a guy with
a championship pedigree and then after
getting sent down to the miners in
anaheim uh with in san diego ended up
becoming all-star in the minor so this
guy's got it done anywhere he's gone
nasher anywhere he's gone
i love it
so it is uh up to me for the last last
pick here and uh it is a goaltender for
me of course gotta finish up the
goaltending squad i'm gonna pick uh
listen this is a guy i'm gonna tell you
biz he is
probably the best nhl
gamer in the nhl that is thatcher demko
this guy is a man on the sticks he has
beaten me before and uh if he can beat
me and chill
i'm going to get him on my all-star
squad so we'll toss them in there all
right guys let's bring it all together
here first i will give you my rundown we
have mcdavid we have dry settle together
we've got kale on defense line two ov
corel the thrill the russian connection
with adam fox at d
uh that third line we got meyer and
hughesy
in net we've got freddy anderson and
demko this line i mean this this is the
picture perfect lineup is what do you
got
the diversity
i got a little bit of everything buddy
i'm gonna sprinkle i'm making a nice
little winning stew all right let's take
a look we got pablo wearing the sea as
he was already given from the national
hockey league but i'm going to give it
to him too that's how much i trust his
goal scoring ability and who be best
pastor in the league who's going to play
with pablo the guy who's going to put
the bread in his basket
cadre of course he's coming in lethal
he's pissed about getting snubbed
originally he's back in
stoner great 200-foot game pavs greasy
in front of the net he's going to get us
the garbage goals we talked about the
loyalty with kells defensive defenseman
which i don't even think you came close
to sniffing and then we finish it off
with the wild card troy terry and
annette
the best goalie on the planet the last
two three seasons andre vasilevskiy and
then the rock behind them the good team
guy the guy if things aren't going well
can step in between the pipes for him
and if things are going well he'll be
there to rub you back he'll be there to
drive your kids to school and do
whatever it is
what it takes to win for the squad so
ladies and gentlemen you know who won
this one
it is
now there is one last surprise edition
uh that we did not tell you beforehand
and because you went first in the draft
i actually do get the first pick so we
are going to do our snubs
we're talking not last man in we're
talking not on an all-star team
players added to your team one
additional roster spot has been added in
and i'm going to tell you my pick off
the rip yeah i already know who it is
who is it it's brad marshawn
it is not
but
listen did you actually think it was
brad because i mean
you know who i am right you know what
i'm looking for we're looking for
content and the king of content in the
nhl right now
none other and trevor zegras will
officially be joining the squad
what
what
get your content biz over brad marchand
did you not hear him miked up on tnt
dropping s bombs and then on top of that
getting the trayway hat trick
against his former rival the montreal
canadiens but they should be relegated
to the ahl that's how bad they are
i got brad marchand not only was he
stubbed he should have been the first
all-star in there because he is a
content factory
you must have lost your mind nasher
has brad marchand ever flipped the puck
over the net and had it batted what he
do has zegras ever won an nhl playoff
game
i i mean it is his rookie year
who's to say i got the rat king brad
marsha i respect your pick and i respect
the way that trevor zegras one of those
tick tock players is reinventing the
wheel i respect that
and i'm sure the fans are gonna love it
but this is all about
w's buddy
honestly biz i think it might be a
like i think it might be a double digit
defeat for you like looking at the list
i mean i i went straight down my list
you were going the opposite direction of
my list starting down in the 20s and
working your way up so
we're in a pretty good spot i think here
yeah well i think you should shut your
mouth
oh you're laughing you think i'm kidding
we'll see you and we'll see in uh the
all-star game there barton vegas all
right biz i i will i'll see you in vegas
and bring some cash with you bring a
duffel bag full of cash and put it on
the line
put your money where your mouth is
uh hey biz i will listen i want every
single person watching this i want you
to reply right now who has the better
team i'm not gonna let this guy get up
in my you're gonna be pissing blood
buddy this is for the just like the rest
of your squad you're going to be pissing
blood they are the ones that decide all
right
take your cowboy hat yeah leave all
right
you want to pick up me
i'm a little intimidated
i gotta get out of here biz it's been a
pleasure
uh good good hanging out and uh we'll
see you guys next time peace